you need to try
um you need to try this barbecue place
yeah in Florida and I'm like no it's
fine that's always [__] bad that's so
dumb it's always bad you're like no but
you don't get it this is like a guy on
the side of the road with like a smoker
and a truck and it's like an overweight
black guy then I'm like all right I'll
try it yeah it's gonna be good but it's
not it's not good like it's like a real
barbecue is like a science
that's crazy
yeah it's like uh you got beakers and
you got to put it in the smoker the
right way yeah yeah you got to be just
the right temperature yeah of course
yeah that comes with it and then that's
how you get that Tangy that's how you
get the flavored yeah I went to the one
that was right here today you ate
barbecue today yeah you [__] traitor
all right what'd you get how was it well
I was like Dickies it's right there
Dickies yeah it's right next to the
ramen place oh yeah and it was just like
whatever but it was very funny while I
was eating there's this like family that
they spoke English but they were having
the hardest time with the menu ever it
was like it was a 10 minute ordeal and
the guy had to have it coming around
he's like this is you get three sides
pick three of these yeah and the guy was
pointing at other stuff it was
hysterical yeah speaking English doesn't
make you intelligent unfortunately yeah
some of the dumbest people don't speak
any other like they speak English you
know yeah it was it was very fun we had
a lady last night it was very funny yeah
Denny's that was we got a horrible
server yeah he started telling me about
that so we got to the restaurant and she
just won't let us talk she's just
interrupting us like Hi how are you okay
don't talk anyways what do you want okay
don't tell me I know what you want yeah
she's like just to let you know I can't
split checks my sir our machine won't do
it well it's I want split checks and
then we were ordering and I'm like is
the cheese with the egg extra and she
was like okay now let me go back and
check check okay do you want cheese with
that I was like is that extra she's like
I gotta go see now let me go check and
then she wouldn't tell me if it was
extra it turns out it was extra she told
me it wasn't I got it with cheese it was
extra
but luckily some the other guy paid for
it
how did you guys go with uh it was well
like that group left and it was just the
guy and his girlfriend I didn't know
they knew each other I didn't know the
guy with the wife knew because they
looked so different they look so
different everyone else looks sort of
the same yeah and they were like six
inches taller yeah and wider yeah a
whole group of people yeah they all knew
each other yeah I've never been to a
Denny's where the servers have it like
have any amount of professionalism at
all no which is what you expect speaking
of like adding flavor like you got to be
a little racist to make a barbecue yeah
you have to be a shitty server you have
to be a shitty server to even get Danny
I imagine yeah
somebody wants food is so good what do
you do it's like uh yeah you should be
able to get the pop copy or yeah because
[__] [__] yeah
that's what Denny's is like it was like
we when she was taking all of our orders
it maybe took her 15 minutes to take all
of our orders and at one point she's
trying to do it and she like puts the
iPad down on the table to kind of It
kind of like made me think they're
ordering off iPads they're ordering off
iPads and when you say all of you you
mean four people four people okay
push the iPad down and I got the feeling
that she put it down so we could maybe
help her yeah she didn't know what was
happening it was like Hey if you guys
know what's happening click something
yeah
it's like what is her job then yeah is
she just like an iPad operator she's
like a there's no way she's the best
demographic iPad there right yeah yeah
that's kind of what it was yeah and then
like it was very fun like at one point
there's like you know the refrigerator
set up and there's nothing in it except
for one LED light yeah and I was like I
don't think they sell Bud Lights here I
think someone brought their part right
that's like the staff fridge yeah and
somebody was like this is gonna be a
long shirt but halfway through
but just one yeah
what does One Bud Light ever do for
anyone just a dead drop it's true you
know just to give it a little gas but
even if it was on the menu who's getting
Bud Light at Denny's that's crazy I
imagine you go to Denny's when you've
had your fill of Butler yeah you should
be done for the night I think it was for
the staff it's for sure yeah we used to
go to the Denny's I used to do this show
in Fort Lauderdale it's close to here
you might have been at the same Denny's
you actually might have been at the same
with the same server
but she was so nice but she was always
frazzled there was never anybody we're
going after like shows it's like
midnight on like a Wednesday yeah and
there's no one else there there's like
maybe one to go order and she can't
handle it and she's crazy and she would
always like I'm pretty sure she was
addicted to drugs because she would
always have like she always have like a
little Band-Aid over her like this arm
right here and she'd always be sweating
even though it was like freezing in the
Denny's and I'd be like I get it sweetie
yeah I've been there it's fine but you
know maybe maybe where you have somebody
else bring my food it out if you don't
mind yeah you have a whole staff of
people like what could be happening
right that it's like it's yeah it was
ridiculous it was very funny though it
was like laughably bad yeah it was
because I said at one point I was like I
thought she was doing a bit to us or she
was like oh I'm gonna do the classic
not take their order correct for 20
minutes
and Captain was like I want to get a
coffee yeah and she was like okay but I
can't split checks and then he was like
okay it's okay I'll get a water and then
she was like are you sure you don't want
a coffee it's like yeah I'm sure and
she's like are you sure she just kept
asking him yeah I wanted a coffee and
then she brought us coffee anyway yeah
she was like don't worry it's on me I
was like it's not me great thank you so
much it was like a hostage situation
yeah she was just trying to like
Gaslight you guys yeah for real then uh
oh yeah they got like these pancakes
where like it has like icing on it the
cinnamon roll pancakes I'm very familiar
yeah you guys got her to draw stuff
which is pretty yeah she was like I can
do anything you want I was like I'll
take a star of David yeah and she's
doing that yeah and then the other guy
ordered a Christmas tree wow this lady
sounds like both the worst and best yeah
ever she was very accommodating but like
just didn't know the steps she didn't
want to listen right she just wanted to
talk and do everything yeah she was
doing like a one-man show
so let me run something about you guys
real quick what do you think jokes by
you yeah
thanks man yeah like a minute what did
you think about that group that group
was fun right they were fun they were
cool people yeah they were very nice
they were chill they were chill
they were sort of nerdy they were they
were super nerdy and I liked that except
for the two the couple that wasn't nerdy
except for the couple that you guys ate
with yeah yeah they were like the ring
leaders they seem like yeah they seem
like they're always trying to convince
somebody to do Molly that was good yeah
they were like the the face of the group
they were like the white people that
represent them yeah
or their agents yeah yeah because the
guy at one point was talking about what
festival or like oh like a thing was he
talking he was talking about like an LSD
Festival yeah they were like just
selling weed and mushrooms and like a
Convention Center of like yeah uh of
like uh like somewhere in Fort
Lauderdale yeah and he was like this is
the best thing ever you guys I think
it's amazing it changed my life
being able to buy mushrooms at the
courtyard of a ballroom area changed my
life yeah all right this is Valhalla
yeah I think it was completely random it
was like I gotta tell you guys something
yeah I like that no they were cool it
was nice sometimes people after shows
are like they're like come on like let's
hang out you're like all right we're all
going to this bar anyways and then you
go and then it's horrible you're like I
shouldn't have been yeah I should have
been here with you they just want to
have a good time but they don't know how
to do it they just like come on let's do
it but yeah it's like they don't know
how to like dude um we had a fun one
once we had a bunch of firefighters
coming oh yeah and I think they were
friends of one of the comedians yeah
they were and they went and just got all
super trash and they're all these like
roided up dudes so they're doing the
thing where they're like putting their
hand on the dartboard and throwing them
they're putting like bottles on their
head in the wrong it was hysterical that
sounds sick
as long as I don't have a bunch of dudes
going now you put your hand if I can
watch somebody else do it they were just
getting sick and it was like it was it
was a small show so the entire show
basically came to this bar like across
town and everyone was there and it's
just very fun eventually a bunch of
slurs are yelled got a little too
excited Fighters a little too excited
you know and I was like all right we'll
go home yeah when I did the uh when I
hosted people get weird like when I
hosted for Shane Gillis in West Palm the
West Palm Improv is connected to the
Copper Blues Bar like they share a
kitchen and so everybody goes there
after and dude the amount of just like
white guy groupies who just wanted to be
close to Shannon just to be able to be
like
yeah
it was so crazy dude it was wild and
people get so weird yeah we're just
trying to play cornhole and like and
like they're trying to like Crush beers
and then dudes are just like I saw you
on a [__] bar stool and they're like
you know when drunk people get to that
level yeah where they don't realize that
they're literally like touching you yeah
yeah and so he was just like like
[__] karate traveling people out of
the way yes it was hilarious you ever
get that like a drunk out like dude
you're so funny yeah I saw your [__] on
Instagram dude so funny nothing makes me
laugh yeah yeah that's the best one
nothing makes me laugh you made me look
kind of laughs a little bit Yeah so it
was just shut up I get it dude you want
to suck my dick yeah
I had a guy last night told me that he
did he used to do comedy in Miami
and then that's a trip that I liked I
liked going down that road to be able to
just talk [__] about how bad comedy in
Miami is yeah and then he was like like
I was watching these guys in these over
mics and I was like I know I'm better
than them and I was like I have a
feeling you did yeah you know if you
have that much confidence you're
probably not that good but you're really
good at convincing yourself that you are
yeah a lot of people who do stand-ups
who are like that yeah yeah you have to
be that was a lot like that's like a
given I don't even care about that like
what can you do on top of that yeah yeah
everyone can have that crazy confidence
and then like and then what you can do
with that is like all that matters
right yeah exactly
yeah because you do kind of I do feel
like there's a level of like borderline
narcissism to even have the idea of like
I bet I could go on stage and entertain
people for sure with nothing else
because you're like I need these 300
people's attention right now yeah yeah
you're like I know it's different if
you've like spent your life and you're
like I've learned to play the guitar
really well and I think I would like to
do that in front of people it's like oh
you but the thought like when you're
about to start stand up is like
I bet that I'm entertaining enough just
being me yeah for these people yeah I
haven't done anything extra that anyone
else hasn't done but for some reason
yeah people should all listen to me
right exactly exactly and the worstest
one is like someone's been doing it for
a long time and they still have that
same delusion it's like oh I don't need
to change anything I'll just be myself
yeah well you have to have that delusion
and then you know only a small sliver of
the people who have that delusion to the
point where they try it are actually
like funny and but there's a lot of
people who are like nah I'm good and
it's like yeah you don't understand that
you don't like some people just don't I
feel like their ears shut off when they
go on stage and it's like you realize
people aren't laughing right oh for sure
but yeah then they make like a Facebook
post it's like I [__] killed tonight
bro there's this guy I won't say his
name just because I feel like this is
actually you've heard me say his name
Josh was talking about last night yeah
he's that way like he's bad been doing
it like a decade and he
we'll post about how people need to quit
and I'm like you need to quit
yeah he's just trying to like run away
from like a gay guy that is trying to
convince himself he's not gay so he's
like extra homophobic yeah like you need
to quit you need to quit yes it's really
self-denial I haven't I have to believe
that some even subconscious level it's
like denial of being like I'm just gonna
pretend I'm the [__] but I kind of deep
down know this isn't going great yeah
because that's like a flip side of the
coin if you have that crazy confidence
yeah it needs to be balanced out by that
self-hatred and like oh yeah I'm nothing
I think that's what makes somebody like
a good comic is being able to be like I
can definitely entertain hundreds of
people but then like last night I
stumbled over a couple words and I came
off stage I was like you [__] idiot
yeah God damn it dude that's always it's
like a very humbling thing because every
time I get off stage the first thing is
something there's something the closure
didn't work as well I did a joke in a
weird order even last night like the
first show was so good and then the
second show after my set I was like what
the [__] I just did I bomb I watched the
tape today it was fine yeah it was going
well yeah but in my head I remember
being up there and being like I [__]
suck yeah but that's like you know it's
better than being like I'm killing right
now it's the best I'm the best yeah for
sure because people are so delusional
like I'll even see post it's like
Bookers are afraid of me it's like dude
shut up oh my God there's a guy never
mind I can't just sit here and [__] talk
the whole software comedy scene well if
it's like you're saying you're awesome
then you're not gonna get as good as
fast as if you hate yourself because if
you hate yourself you're gonna be like
let's change this and let's do that
differently you're critiquing yeah it
was
yeah you got to change something if you
hate yourself you eventually have to go
well I gotta change what do you think
about Ukraine
what do I think about Ukraine that needs
to change bad yeah I hope Ukraine is
really working on itself it's very silly
that they're just allowed to wear GoPros
in war yeah there's like I have fun
I think it is kind of sick that like
there's somebody in the Ukraine who is
like this will be good content yeah you
know they're like flipping it up they're
even putting like captions and stuff and
they're like it's gonna be good somebody
has filmed the war in Ukraine and then
opened Adobe Premiere Pro yeah added
captions to it yes yeah this is crazy
it's awesome so we do for stand-up
they're doing for war exactly like oh
this clip bombed today
also I bombed a tank earlier I love how
they all have their own Isis music in
every region of the world they do they
have this awful sounding music That's So
ethnic that you're like this is only for
you and they put it they get to do it
because they're the ones that are
killing people yeah I wonder if there's
any like celebrity like like terrorist
Music Makers you know what I mean like
the music that you yeah like when like
any music that you hear over any
background of any like beheading video
or like any Isis video they're like
that's true I wonder if they get like
residuals from it right they're gonna
get their own version of that tick tock
song yeah no no no no no no no yeah
it's like Jabar is actually kind of the
Drake of the Middle East actually well I
watched like I've heard of [__] like
this crazy thing where they're like they
I just pour so much money into their
execution videos it's insane really
they're like really well budgeted like a
huge budget yeah so they use like 4K
cameras they edit them they put music
behind them it's crazy because it's just
they're trying to you know do propaganda
their biggest export yeah so they're
like might as well put mine that would
be a wild job to be like I'm a
videographer and they're like what for
you're like I don't just don't worry
about it don't worry about it it's for
government stuff yeah yeah and you're
just at home like with it like tear
strolling down your eye just editing
yeah
for Isis
the color coordination on this guy's
blood real quick they get tired of it
they're like another video I have to
edit oh yeah oh many of these people are
you gonna this guy was standing two foot
he's backlit they [__] backlit this
man I can't do anything with this wife
just like honey will you take a break to
come have dinner he's like I'm almost
done this is the last beheading
of this week they got 30 today yeah it's
crazy yeah or he's like I can't wait to
get away from my [__] wife and start
editing people getting killed yeah he
Brews like a coffee and he's like
oh man nothing relaxes me on a Monday
morning like a good Isis beheading he
props his feet up and he like yeah it
was funny you don't ever think I've
never thought about that there is
somebody who had to edit that video yeah
they're very well edited because it was
like a comparison between like how it
wasn't like some weird like gross video
but it was just saying how like the
cartel does it compared to Isis the
cartel just filmed something on a tape
then send the tape to the news and then
the news doesn't the news is like let's
play this on the news this is great yeah
and then Isis will be like they're uh
it's like when someone produces their
own comedy special yeah Isis wants
creative control over their videos yeah
I respect that honestly as an artist
yeah they probably have better
production than most comedians yeah for
sure yeah dude I would bet yeah we need
to Outsource our video production to
Isis we can get them off the desert into
the office it'd be cool having your
comedy videos edited by the same guy
edited like a high profile beheading
that's like how you get brought out
that's your credit yeah this guy if
you've seen any of his videos on his
Instagram it's actually edited by the
same guy who edits Isis
please give it up for Captain Ryan have
you seen his videos ended by musafar
if you've seen this video you supported
Isis yeah
that's amazing praise all our guests
um Trevor Morris corpse in the middle
yeah dude right we said that last night
yeah and we looked up how he died
yeah he doesn't think very comfortably
he needs to scoot closer to Hans I can't
scoot there's no [__] you want to
scoot this all the way so you have a
back well there's no like back thing all
right
yeah I've never done a live there we go
no this is comfortable as [__] look how
comfortable he looks
now I really look like a corpse corpses
the hollow Night Before Christmas they
like your feet dude I know yeah
you give that dude that should be that
should be Instagram subscription content
yeah only feet you're your only fans
yeah I sold the foot picture one time
really yeah that's actually the fake
account on Tinder that was a sexy lady
but it was actually a man and he said
okay he sent me a message he said here's
the deal I'm a gay man I will pay you
money for a foot picture wow and I said
I sent him my cash app and immediately
he sent me twenty dollars and I didn't
have to send another footpeg at that
point yeah
as a content creator as a content
creator and as a man of my word that's a
man it was a fellow horny person you
know well I'm a very horny person and I
I also have a foot fetish I've never
asked to pay for one you have a foot
fetish yeah I heard you talk about that
on stage yeah but I've never I don't
believe there's a a point where you get
so horny for it you feel the need so
wait how far does it put like what do
you mean because it's so different my
mouth it's it's different with like
everyone it's crazy okay so talk to
other people so like me yeah
hello how do you feel about foot well
like um like if a girl's dirty feet that
gives me like the ick okay to her in
general like I don't want to like even
see all right and that's it just like
clean feet I'm not doing like real stuff
with them like people like pour cheese
on them or something what are you doing
to these feet yeah what do you do I
enjoy a good foot rub or like a you have
a toe in my mouth yeah toe in your mouth
that's about it that's not you can't
really go like any further it's not like
a feta you could leave yeah [__] the the
heat yeah I've done that bottom of their
feet
yeah the souls yeah yeah
dude let's see yeah one in the fussy two
in the middle yeah he's like girl I
don't want that snake ass [__] tonight
I did have a girlfriend one time who we
were out and then we went home and she
laid on my bed like stomach down and she
had her feet I have a picture of it and
the bottom of her feet were [__]
black I would and the rest of her was
not least she was one when she
barefooted it was no she had sandals on
she was probably getting old dirty I was
like where the [__] were you before this
that's yucky it's like running around in
the gravel I don't know what it was yeah
it was pouring apart it was just a
temporary thing you think you can wipe
it down with a baby wipe I imagine that
the bottom of her feet weren't
permanently black but it was weird to be
like your feet are [__] dirty no
that's just god dude I want to see if I
could find I want to find that picture
what so you're like hold still I'm gonna
take a picture she didn't know I don't
think to this day that she probably has
she doesn't even know about this picture
yeah and she blocked me hasn't unblocked
me for like three years guys can't get
the egg makes no sense at all now dude
if like that's not true no because guys
won't [__] girls that are below like a
four yeah that's very true yeah bad
smells will get me smells is bad yeah
like if I see a girl like I've been in
public where I'm looking at an
attractive girl but something in the
public sphere is a very bad smell oh and
it it [__] that in person for me yeah
like a sewage drain will break or
something yeah that's why hot girls hate
hanging around sewage lines yeah this is
little Little Miss Sunshine dude they're
tearing you up bro oh my God
I loved this the guy in the middle and
Little Miss Sunshine what is it even his
Little Miss Sunshine you've never seen
that movie no it's great there's a one
of the characters looks like you like
you I thought he looked like Dano Dano
from from uh There Will Be Blood
I don't know I don't know I forgive you
I get Paul I've gotten that one before
since um what movie was that came out
the Riddler
oh yeah well that's the guy that's yeah
that's because right when I started a
Little Miss Sunshine yeah okay yeah yeah
I've gotten Paul but Paul Dano has in
that and a little bit Sunshine he has
like darker hair oh okay and he's very
he's a lot more like scrawny kind of
yeah no offense because um no no no
you're scared like you're a skinny white
Palm nanotypes can either be like super
scary or like they're attacking
themselves it's like an inward thing
yeah which is better
so yeah he just like punches himself on
the side of the head
yeah yeah that's next level that's next
level white guy rage yeah that's better
you've ever punched yourself in the side
of the head yeah welcome welcome to the
team brother you listen to Papa Roach
you go there yeah you go to like heavy
metal concert that all checks out dude
speaking of bad smells those smell
horrific what Papa Roach concerts just
any heavy metal concert I imagine so
white people that I've got to take care
of them I've gotten like dragged to one
yeah and the people already smell bad so
when there's like a Convention of them
all in like a gross room it's horrifying
I went to a hardcore concert one time
and the girl I was with had a broken
foot so we were in the Ada section with
all the other [__] disabled people
yeah it was sick because we got an
aerial view and I just watched a girl
get [__] destroyed oh that's good and
you could tell she went like because she
wanted to but like I watched her like
get into the mosh just immediately
forearms to the face beautiful and she
went down got back up somebody backed
into her and you know like they go back
and forth and they like throw their yeah
it's like crazy and so just back into
her she went down I didn't see her for
the rest oh my God yeah that girl died
so yeah yeah she's [__] at girls no
longer with us and she died at a knocked
loose concert it's hard to be a girl
yeah it is or disabled person at an
event yeah a solid video today like this
uh like kid with Down Syndrome at like
WrestleMania or the Royal Rumble that
sounds like you mean like half of the
people who are at wrestling yeah yeah
they were just filming him and I guess
something happened like someone turned
on another person and he starts crying
and he starts going I need to get in the
ring right now I need to go I need to
get in the ring right now
that's a disabled person's call to
action yeah he's like I need to help him
right now at the storyline yeah that's
who it's for it was it was beautiful are
you are you guys wrestling fans no no no
I'm not I was back in John Cena's Heyday
I was but yeah I don't understand it now
I know like I know like Tony is a huge
wrestling fan yeah dad used to film it I
just can't your dad like for WWE like
you know the camera on the crane
wow he did that and it was just like
yeah this is there for some big [__]
yeah he was like this is just the
weirdest thing ever I can't find a
picture it's just like
is it like real or fake it's like both
it's like what is the point of it if
it's fake like you're just watching some
guys
uh vision of what your favorite
characters are like gonna do yeah yeah I
mean like it's like theater basically
yeah it's like a really intense theater
theater at that point but it's I don't
know
I have a hard like disconnect in my head
of like if you know like
like if you're watching a movie you're
like I know Matt Damon didn't go to
space yeah right like you get that but
Matt Damon also if you ran into Matt
Damon he wouldn't be like no I went to
space yeah exactly like wrestlers are
like I'm a professional athlete yeah
like but you also are an actor but they
do like train and stuff that's yeah you
can't knock the uh the level of
athleticism you have to have to be a
professional wrestler
but
I don't know
it's like if it's so great why don't you
just actually fight and then we can see
the drama from there hey join the MMA
[__] it's like you're basically in it
just for the drama
but some of those guys are more like
actors than they are athletes oh for
sure John Cena is in every The Rock dude
yeah highest paid actors in the world
now yeah that's true the highest paid
actor I think for sure but no one like
respects him as an actor they're like oh
it's another shitty movie that's true
it's just like oh him and Kevin Hart are
yelling at each other you're seeing
friends again yeah oh these guys get
along oh my God yeah what what new
setting are they going to be in now are
they going to be in the woods they're
going to be in the river
I'd like to see that Kevin Hart yeah and
Kevin Hart starring the remix
yeah that's the thing is like we have
all like that's the next step and
eventually they will run out of ideas
but now it's like with like people's
sensibilities we can't do that which is
unfortunate because that'd be so funny
yeah because people are like no you're
actual Nazis but it's like no we're just
joking about it but it's like yeah
there's people that are too close to
actual Nazis and they should be
comfortable maybe Kevin Hart like the
officer and that would make it all okay
silly little black officer yeah
single-handedly being the largest
huge Jew in the Holocaust super Juice
yeah fictional history yeah that's so
funny yeah
yeah oh this is a tall pile of Ash
Jesus Christ yeah I think we got the
wrong person Kevin Hart is Hitler that'd
be good that would be hilarious that'd
be good black Hitler I was just trying
to high-five a guy and he did the same
sound back to me
yeah instead of the instead of the I'm
not gonna do it yeah that's good it's a
good thing yeah it ends up being like a
yeah they're dabbing each other
okay yeah yeah Kevin Hart is Hitler
that's um yeah someone make that happen
that's the only thing I want to see from
Kevin Hart in the Rock I don't want to
see Jumanji seven I know
we've because we've already if we've
already run out of ideas where we're
like remaking like yeah the mermaid is
black Kevin Hart is in yeah like the
rock gets off the train Kevin Hart's
like man you built like a train yeah
that's the first laughing yeah I want
you to run a train on me yeah
yeah and then they eventually we'll get
to the point Spider-Man there's been
seven Spider-Mans dude yeah who's your
favorite Spider-Man though I don't know
original Toby Maguire that's the only
one I've seen yeah yeah Toby McGuire I
grew up with them that's like my Santa
Claus right exactly yeah that makes
sense
and then you're 19. so yeah that's crazy
I don't think the club knows that he's
nice they don't they have been serving
in alcohol so once yeah I haven't been
just buying people well luckily We're
not gonna go back to the Miami Improv
tonight which is where we're performing
yeah
yeah I mean I can't believe they served
him no they brought him a water shot
just like that yeah and I was like guys
I'm so [__] up right now this is crazy
oh God I can't drive home no I yeah I
hosted for somebody here who would do
that like people would send them drinks
they're like if they send me drinks just
send me shots of water on stage that's
so smart it was smart but it was like
he's taking 30 shots yeah
like watching from the back I'm like
that's crazy that's so funny that's
comedy yeah they're like get him a
whiskey shot and they give him a water
shot what is happening
yeah well it's a little it's a little
watered down we ran it through a Purina
or a purifier what is that Purina dog
food yeah
have you seen people do that or they'll
put fake shots yeah or they'll put like
alcohol through something brown doesn't
it make it better in the like yeah
that's what one of my co-workers is
talking about it [__] up your filter
though I'm sure yeah at that point if
you're if you're like I want to drink
but the taste just like stop being such
a [__] yeah yeah that's crazy just
drink you have a problem at that point
do pills yeah or just get a mixed drink
yeah we're gonna just drown it in
Gatorade or something that's the easier
way to go don't do pills it's a new
thing all the college kids do now is
they get the jug and they fill it
halfway full of water and then vodka and
Gatorade that's what the college kids
are doing yeah because they're like
because you know they want to drink
water while they drink oh so they can be
hydrated yeah yeah that's crazy it's
crazy we've reached a level in society
of like where self-care is high enough
for people where they're like while I'm
drinking Everclear I need to also make
sure that's literally what it is that's
crazy it's a half of a half a gallon of
water than Everclear Gatorade and like
oh it's in the drugs where people can't
like drug my drinks and it's just like
but you look like a dick walking around
yeah everybody who will walk around he's
like the cool his name's Drew Ella he's
a comic he's [__] hilarious coolest
black dude I mean just [__] he's
pretty hard to do because black people
are already cool yeah I mean he's he's
like Lupe Fiasco cool
that weird reference but yes like a
skateboarder he's not skater he's like
very like he loves like house music and
like oh yeah
he'll be like cool he'll have like a
sweet like very miami-ass like button up
with like a fur jacket he's like a cool
guy yeah but he'll walk around with a
jug of distilled water it's like yeah
like you're ruining him it makes me look
like a nerd immediately no offense but
you look like a guy that would walk
around with a jug of water that's fair
but that fits that fits you for like a
cool Miami guy that doesn't no to
someone yeah because if I show you the
jug of water like just got out of the
gym yeah he's carb loading honestly dude
I just am happy that you guys think I
look like I go to the gym we have the
look The haircuts the hair yeah and
you're like six four in the outfit this
is just how I I just I came out this way
that's good yeah I came out six four so
you don't work out I mean not really
like once or twice but you don't need to
did people think that you do
I mean when I have my shirt on maybe
yeah and then like a like a lady I like
take my shirt off they're like oh yeah
it's not like nobody's ever like whoa
but I think sometimes people are like
that's not what I thought would be under
there yeah now he's more relatable I
like him more now I get it now now I see
why he's so nice to me yeah he has
nothing to back it up yeah
I mean size is like important
being 6'4 is uh that's yeah that's so
great I mean there's nothing better than
yeah for now for now my back is far like
my back is [__] my knees are [__] so
it's not great yeah because my body's
just head to care and I hear for a long
time you're here for a good time I'm
here for a good time you heard it here
but it's so crazy to see girls that are
like 5'4 be like I like him he's six
four it's like [__] you would do it
good with like someone who's five eleven
yeah you don't need yeah it is funny
when women will be 5'4 and
tall and wide and be like you need to be
six foot like you're lucky if anybody
looks at you yeah my favorite I've been
seeing a lot of recently is all these
clips were like uh like a guy will go up
and try to talk to a girl on the bar
who's clearly into the guy but then her
like hideous friend will come up and
just be like no yeah that's always fun
yeah she's not it's very fun yeah she's
like if I'm not getting laid no one is
yeah exactly but it'll be like Chemistry
Between the two and then you have to be
like fine I'll [__] both of you
well she knows she she thinks that
what's gonna happen to her is going to
happen to her friend she's like oh I
know how this ends they look at you and
they're disgusted and they run away so
they're like I'm Gonna Save her from
that yeah you're gonna go home your yeah
does your apartment smell like cats yeah
they won't like that then you get naked
and they'll realize that you stink and
then they'll leave it's like that only
happens to you you troll yeah that's
true yeah yeah
I hate women
yeah dude I [__] hate women no I'm
honestly glad I'm not a woman because I
think men would be way worse in terms of
rape and stuff like what do you wait
wait like if you're not hot it's just
over for you like you're not gonna get a
certain type of guy yeah it's just
impossible but if you're like a dude and
you're at least five ten five nine then
the sky's the limit as long as you can
you know economically succeed that's a
big thing down here it's like having uh
having money dude everybody's got
something that they think you love
you're you're instigating it you know
that right I like it I like it Brandon
it's all like really abstract things too
yeah we could kill someone in here and
it'd be fun
Gary Coleman is Alive and Well he
changed his name to Bill Bond he manages
12 ant farms behind Long John Silver's
that person sounds like they have
schizophrenia yeah who is Brandon Ward
welcome to the YouTube comments oh I
know Brandon Wardle who's Brandon you
remember the dicks out for harambe guy I
know the Canadian he's he's
fine uh I guess the facial structure
kind of makes sense honestly oh I've
seen yeah at this point they're just
going you look like this other skinny
white guy yeah that's that's why I like
that yeah and you're right I am
instigating it for sure yeah it's more
common it's more traction I guess I
think people don't like seeing young
people because they're like oh uh this
guy shouldn't be like they they want a
gatekeep like oh you can't come up yet I
do yeah I do kind of feel like I mean
I'm not I'm 29 but I feel like it's more
with like the crowds where like if
you're doing if you're performing for a
crowd that's like older they're not like
immediately like um let this guy make me
like it's very much like you're a kid so
why do you have yeah I have one of you
at home because if you're on stage
so they're like I don't really know
if I like this yeah like oh this is
supposed to be a leader he's higher up
and he's elevated and he's talking
loudly
but he's a child it's just they're
thinking like they're an animal they're
like
oh he's gonna out dominate me because
I'm old and to be serious
yeah exactly basically I could yeah
they're scared of you they're scared of
being out Alpha that's how I'm gonna end
the weekend yeah she should we should
all punch a guy at the end of your set
tonight there's Late Show said I'm gonna
be like thanks I'll it will be in the
lobby and as every old person walks
through the lobby I'm just gonna [__]
yeah just to start dominance I'm gonna
stage dive tonight I'll never work the
club again but it'll be yeah everybody
that's what people are looking for they
want to be dominated that's there'd be a
sick ass news article though that would
be and the picture that is you just
slamming a bottle of something yeah
fought every elderly person on the show
that's good that's good publicity right
there dude there's no bad publicity yeah
it's not like an allegation or something
horrible you just punching every bridge
have you ever got that you look like
John Leguizamo
yeah is that the guy
um he's got Latin American History For
Dummies yes I've actually been told that
yeah yeah you know what I remember are
you Cuban or no I'm white and Native
American
it's a good Mexican and then the white I
haven't looked into the white portion I
feel like I just that's the part of me
that I don't want to be like too proud
of you know what I mean yeah so it's
hard to be proud of that I think I'll be
white but native yeah you know so I feel
that
I uh yeah that's what the white part of
me is like kind of oppressing the Native
American part of me like it's a constant
battle inside of you it is it's an
intern about it there's two wolves and
some wolves
yeah but the American one loves the
white one the American one mashed
potatoes yeah the American cheese out
eating your Native American one and yes
getting obese I killed all of its bison
yeah
but uh oh yeah so what do you think
about the uh
this shows here in Miami Improv
the Miami Improv
I they think they've been wonderful
yeah so far we had the best Thursday
show that I've ever done at this club
specifically the Thursday show is
probably my favorite really I think the
Friday was probably my favorite but they
were close yeah Thursday was good they
were small yet Mighty yes I think the
last show we did was like my favorite
but that's like right when I kind of
organized everything that one was good
too yeah I didn't like the early show as
much as you liked it I had a great time
yeah I don't know yeah it really shows
all right
it was like kind of whatever
it's still good they're all great like
I'm like talking yeah
thank you if you've come to the Miami
Improv yeah where they served him
yeah
I have a real ID that says I'm 23.
yeah you have a real idea that says
you're 23 and you're yeah I was trying
to do it from them we were at the uh
Dennis Iowa we were at the Denny's and
he was like looking through his wallet
and I was like what are you doing he's
like oh it's just rifling through my IDs
yeah well like I was looking to see how
much cash I had to pay the guy who's
doing the tax did you pay him yeah I
give him like four bucks
I gave him a disrespectful amount of
money well I just got a side so it was
like four bucks but like while I was
doing it seeing if I had the cash the
lady was like are you paying now and I
was just like no I'm just looking at my
IDs like I try to get her away she just
couldn't handle any curveballs
she's like I thought you guys were gonna
pay at the end if you try to pay me now
I'll [__] lose it yeah I'm gonna
freak the [__] out yeah yeah she was
close to it because you're probably
still are you in school no no sir yeah
get like an associate it's probably
online in what I don't know some
[__] yeah like video editing or
something do you believe in your dreams
don't go to college that's true mighty
words yeah yeah total waste of time
mechanical engineering yeah that kind of
that's it it's just a status symbol to
fit into High Society yeah but other
than that if you're not going to be a
part of high society there's really no
point yeah
that's true I have no interest I dropped
out of college because I got addicted to
drugs and then
tried to go back and then I failed one I
tried to go back and take one class I
was like I'll dip my toe in and then I
failed because I was still addicted to
drugs and then I moved here and started
doing stand up and I was like this
should this should this will work out
yeah I really put all my all my eggs in
this basket that's it's good though to
put your eggs in a basket because you
can just be passionate about something
yeah I mean it's yeah I mean I have no
like real like work like I've like have
worked in a rehab and I sold cars for
six months that's like the only work
experience yeah I have so like if this
doesn't work out I guess I just have to
go work at a rehab again like yeah yeah
I work in a breakfast restaurant which
like I just worked there because the
hours right so I just show up in your
comments and do [__] all until I leave
which is it's not like we're that much
further behind than most people because
like it really doesn't matter if you
commit yourself to a company for 10
years they're just gonna fire you if
they want to yeah yeah it's like [__]
up like so many people that I know that
like aren't Comics like their whole life
is just like whatever their job is and
then if they lose that then you don't
have your identity at all yeah and you
don't control that yeah you don't
control that like I think like stand up
like you might not like blow up and you
might blow up and then
say a word on a podcast you shouldn't
say or something like that but they
can't you can't they can't stop you on
every single platform and Stage from
doing stand-up yeah so it's like it's
just talking to people right you can
always find a way to do that yeah
I think uh it's working for yourself
like if you're working for a company
you're putting all this energy into some
mysterious being that's hopefully going
to reward you but if you're doing
stand-up you're working on yourself and
you're improving and all that uh work is
like turns into something tangible as
opposed to like in a company it's like
it it goes to someone else right it's
like you're building something for like
a a corporation to make a better like to
turn in better numbers for a quarter or
like their annual you know their annual
returns and it's like you got paid the
same you got the same gratification out
of it yeah like yeah stand up or really
anything that you do for yourself like
any sort of like that's the future
everyone's going to be doing that soon
and everything else is just going to be
done by a computer so why not just skip
to what we're going to be doing anyways
yeah do you ever worry that like AI will
take over stand up
uh
uh I don't think anyone would like to go
to that no yeah that wouldn't be fun
unless it was like the best show ever
but it could but in theory it could be
because it's got the wealth of knowledge
and humor but yeah I don't think that it
I nah I think there will always be a
market for people talking to each other
yeah and even if a computer can do it
better I don't think it's that that's
not what we're looking for we're not
looking for the perfect conversation
we're looking for
uh connection to other people yeah
that's true that's a good point because
it's like you could if you want to just
laugh like you know like the internet is
full of [__] memes and hilarious
pictures yeah yeah and people scroll
through that [__] all day but there are
still people who go I'm gonna buy a
ticket and go to the comedy club tonight
yeah and so yeah you know that's very
true yeah you can save money
do you want to talk to people strangers
[__] yeah dude I would love to talk to
strangers
honestly the show's 7 30 or 7 tonight
seven today seven today
hopefully this works
okay it's working my favorite comic
or now live
please come at us with any questions
right on me that's horrifying
unfortunately vertical video doesn't
work Trevor Moore Trevor Moore's corpse
yeah Trevor yeah if you want to talk to
us come uh on IG DJ Hans Kim
of people already requesting that's fine
yeah go live with Gucci naked
all right you said you wanted to be on
the line
what's up
family oh these are the whitest guys
I've ever seen in my life
yeah speaking of Whitest Kids you know
we got Trevor Morin yeah what's up guys
Trevor Moore here answering uh doing it
doing a q a
no no
no
East Arizona
nice hell yeah that's like the Florida
of the Southwest
Phoenix Arizona you have any questions
for us we can we're giving out life
advice
do you respect women pretty much we're
in uh
Phoenix Arizona while it's [__]
Arizona [__] uh Super Bowl goddamn
emotions going down all right you have
tickets to the Super Bowl are you just
gonna go to a bar
you have tickets to the Super Bowl or
are you not that rich yet I think he
hijacked it yeah
he's doing his own thing
[Music]
Tallahassee [__]
hey how's
do you want to know how to make money
so this guy's just vlogging at this
point Hey so uh how did you uh get to
Arizona do you uh regret going there or
do you think it's a great place for
white people to be white
[Music]
it's funny that white people always go
to places where their skin can't handle
it foreign
[Music]
and then they become Filipinos yeah they
evolve like Pokemon that's why we have
all these white skin whitening things
just because like if we don't then we
just turn Mexican oh my God
all right that's the scariest thing to
turn into
right now
huh
this guy's getting tired of it
what'd you say
where are you guys at right now
uh the hotel behind you guys
we're in Florida we're near Miami
Tallahassee
Panhandle
your friend behind you sounds like Tony
Hinchcliffe
you guys look like a deer's worst
nightmare
look like what you look like a deer's
worst nightmare
[Music]
[Laughter]
this this city right here watch out for
the cactus or cacti they're both
acceptable
all right so many people
[Music]
this is crazy
this guy sucks
yeah I love cocaine
how many people can you accept at the
same time oh this guy looks awesome how
you doing man
you look like a kill Tony fan
can they hear me
can you hear me I'm resting
what's up
uh
uh soon
thank God that guy was crazy
I was in uh Massachusetts Springfield
no by myself
yeah this is Captain this is Matt Ross
what's up what's up dude we're giving
life advice I think
uh I need you to give me some tips on
how to get some [__]
uh there it is Step number one I would
say go up to them and be like hey
um do you want to see me fly a drone
yeah dude
Hans loves drones yeah okay all right
yeah it's big buy a drum buy a drone
1800 yeah it's only like eighteen
hundred dollars
okay only eighteen hundred yeah yeah not
a big buy it off Amazon is your account
Hans you can use my account but you got
to use your own credit card
and then you fly it yeah you just you
just apply it you just maneuver it like
a champ and then you go right and then
they suck your penis yeah it's pretty
cool
and then you film it with the Drone yeah
you get aerial shots
yeah two birds of one stone
uh just just have something more
interesting than the girl
to do
well like some mushrooms or something or
some acid yeah yeah
what is on your neck Hans it's called a
microphone I'm in the industry
Hans is famous
yeah we gotta yeah we gotta be miked up
out here
yeah you wish you could suck Tony's [__]
I do I do I do
yep my mouth has tasted things that
a lot of men
would be would be privileged to take
another not yet
another dude really yeah that's crazy
how was that it was fine it was just
like Hey we're doing it was it kind of
uncomfortable yeah it was just like very
delicate like it could easily get [__]
up yeah at any moment how well did you
know the other guy I knew him all right
he was like yeah oh okay oh that's good
that's sick yeah it was like this girl
is a freak it was after a show
and you know it happened
it was like yeah she was down for it and
then I was like I don't really care I
just met her it's not like I have any
ego
yeah so yeah it was fun yeah it was he
didn't really like it yeah yeah I can't
I can't imagine being super into it I
have a joke about it but it's just I
just don't know how into it I'd be
yeah I don't want to accidentally lock
eyes with like one of the homies while
my dick is out yeah exactly we're like
What if I just like what if I hear him
moan and then I just know what one of my
boys sounds like when he's moaning yeah
I feel like there's got to be like a
treaty like a no moaning treaty no man
it's like you don't look me in my eyes
and we both don't make noises yeah it
will be weird for her just weird silent
sex
but
that's that's the rules yeah or maybe a
casual conversation between the two of
you yeah I think it might have been
improved if there was music playing in
the background oh yeah for sure yeah I'm
not a big fan of music during sex like
one of just normal one-on-one sex yeah
but if there was another guy there I
would need something Kid Rock yeah so
you could silently moan to the beat yeah
yeah so I know I can hear it I just have
like a rhythm just out of the beats per
minute to stay on yeah yeah the focus on
that so I don't focus on like my buddy
with his dick out yeah well thanks for
coming on the show hope to see you later
dude
yeah this guy really likes the steak oh
yeah it was awesome I'm actually very
hungry all right see ya
wait what time is the show tonight seven
I got seven yeah
probably slide there soon
oh yeah I gotta change because I gotta
put pants on and I gotta grab my
[__]